hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's what I in a Dave
review is going to look a little bit
different because instead of critiquing
a famous youtubers video I'm going to be
looking briefly at five everyday users
on the App tik-tok who specifically had
labeled their what I in a day videos for
weight loss now this was a highly
requested video by all of you so even
though I totally feel like a wee bit too
old for this app I downloaded it and I
proceeded to search using the hash tags
what a in a day and weight loss you guys
know I love you a lot when I put myself
through hours of this torture now before
we get too into the actual videos and my
thoughts on the users meals I want to of
course give my geminal disclaimer that
the information in these videos is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always speak to a
health care provider about your unique
healthcare needs
you should also never take nutrition
advice directly from platforms like
tik-tok or even YouTube finally this
video in particular may be really
triggering for those of you who may have
a complicated relationship with food or
a history with disordered eating so if
you need to like peace out here do what
works best for you and know that there
are plenty of amazing awesome videos
that may help support you through
improving your relationship with food ok
so let's get into things starting with
Exhibit A by at Cassidy flood 23 I'm
gonna play these videos twice so that
you have a little bit more time to
actually watch them
[Music]
[Music]
Wow okay so the total that she gives at
the end of this video is just over a
thousand calories this is not enough
food I mean not for normal life not even
for weight loss and in addition to this
being so low in calories I'm just not
seeing any protein or fat at dinner and
not enough fat or carbs in general the
only meal that I kind of like is the
lunch because we have a little bit of
lean beef we've got some rice who got
some asparagus but the portions are so
small I'm really not surprised that she
needs one of those sugar free energy
drinks to get her through the day
now the comments in this particular
video are definitely a mixed bag so some
are suggesting that it's way too few
calories which it is and some saying
that our day looks amazing or defending
her by saying it's actually more than
what they particularly might eat
thankfully when I looked at Cassidy's
channel as a whole I did notice that
most of her other what I today kind of
videos offer a little bit more calories
and a better balance of protein carbs
and vegetables still probably not enough
as in one video I just saw basically
like two meals and a protein shake but
in another one there's like a solid
three meals and even a few cookies in
there of course I am here hoping that
that video that I just watched was like
an off day but judging by her purposeful
calorie counting throughout the clip I
have to assume that these are actual
planned goals and that my friends I
would have to say houston we have a
problem next okay so let's look at my
exhibit to buy at daily dream
uh whoa okay well I don't know Matt's
this day has probably like 750 calories
and I'm being really generous on the
chocolate portion obviously we need more
calories more protein more fat just
basically more of everything like those
veggie noodles for example they look
awesome delicious but I don't see any
protein in here which seems like a
missed opportunity and an apple and just
a few almonds for breakfast
like no this is likely to do more
metabolic damage than actually result in
weight loss but I will actually talk
more about that very soon and when I
looked at this users profile a little
bit more I see that she's clearly
outlined her weight loss journey she
mentions her starting weight her current
weight and her goal weight and also
starts almost every video standing on
the scale I mean talk about triggering
now the comments in this video are
actually really supportive which is
shocking and kind of disappointing for a
750 calorie day there is lots of love
for that stir-fry which I guess was kind
of the only real meal that she had also
a lot of people saying that they're like
really happy for her and a lot of people
saying that they're the same weight as
her with the same goals as her so that
they're kind of in this together now yes
it's obviously really nice to have a
community that supports your goals and
cheers you on I mean weight loss is
definitely not easy so this may feel
really good for this person I think her
name's joy to get some positive
reinforcement on her weight loss journey
however that reinforcement can actually
be a really slippery slope when the
behaviors used to reach those goals are
really problematic research has shown
that
women are more sensitive to negative and
positive reinforcement when it comes to
weight loss and that even rewards can be
associated with binge eating and other
disorderly compensatory behaviors for
this reason I always say that well you
may think it's a nice thing to
compliment somebody on their weight loss
their willpower or their general
commitment to their diet you never
really know what's going on in the
background or what your well-meaning
compliments might trigger so if you want
to actually truly support someone's
healthy behaviors rather than
complimenting you know somebody on their
looks or their weight or their body
maybe instead of focus on non aesthetic
aspects of their behaviors so maybe you
could say something like wow your lunch
looks super yummy and well-balanced or
tell them that their exercise class
sounds really fun and that you would
love to join in we can still be
cheerleaders without putting such an
emphasis on weight and appearance which
research actually suggests may have a
much more long-lasting effect on health
anyway all right so back to what not to
do in this particular account I noticed
a number of comments suggesting that she
needed to cut out wore foods from her
diet
you know how fewer carbs or give up the
diet coke for water it's not actually
even worth me commenting on if these are
good or bad suggestions for weight loss
or good health because that would be a
moot point and really not the point of
this particular video anyways but the
issue is that this woman is clearly
already severely restricting I would say
to the point of potential starvation in
some cases I would never ever tell
somebody even if they still wanted to
lose more weight to restrict even more
when they're starting from a place like
this next okay so moving along to my
exhibit three buy at back off sis let's
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
wow so the description here says that
this has 550 calories so that is truly
concerning and this has 14,000 likes so
yeah I mean there's literally just one
actual meal here and it's pretty low
calorie one at that and even still I
would want to see that like tofu
stir-fry thing times three in the day to
make this even marginally adequate so
yeah I'm feeling pretty concerned about
this account I did manage to watch a few
of this person's other videos and I saw
a lot of the same scary themes so
basically just vegetables and fruit and
one very low calorie meal one day that
meal is like avocado toast another it's
like a salad with like a couple beans
one day it's literally an ounce of trail
mix and grapefruit she also posts the
calories for pretty much every one of
these weight-loss days and on day 30 of
her diet it had just 350 calories yeah
this is pretty dangerous and problematic
across the board now when I read the
comments I was at least relieved to see
a lot of people pointing out that it
just wasn't enough food and that it
could potentially damage her metabolism
and her health and that is definitely
true I mean research has repeatedly
shown that consistently under consuming
calories can significantly decrease the
number of calories that your body burns
a great example of this is
the biggest loser research while of
course it's expected that the number of
calories that your body needs to
maintain a lower body weight will be
fewer than the number of calories needed
to maintain a higher body weight what
wasn't expected and what was found in
the research was the additional 500
calorie reduction in resting metabolic
rate in other words as an example if you
needed 2,000 calories to hold steady at
150 pounds for example maybe you would
be expected to need 1,500 calories to
hold steady at 130 pounds but what they
were finding was that you would actually
need to consume only a thousand calories
to maintain that 20-pound weight loss
it's no wonder then that so many people
gain back the weight that they lose and
they gain more I'm not saying this of
course to scare people who have dieted
or to shame people who maybe already
feel ashamed for severely restricting
calories in the past I mean this is not
your fault
you are simply doing what you've been
taught to do by diet culture I don't
know how
really you could do anything else if
this is the pervasive messaging that is
found in diet culture it's not you it's
them now personally I am less concerned
about people's damaged metabolisms as I
am about the psychological harm these
crazy low meal plans actually are
promoting there will absolutely be a ton
of vulnerable viewers who are going to
watch this and think that this is a
normal or a healthy plan especially when
we are also seeing her post her weight
loss progress on the scale every day I
am so disappointed that this information
is so easily accessible on an app
without any disclaimers whatsoever but
also I am not particularly surprised
let's take a look at exhibit 4 by at
healthy vegetarian team
okay so this one is mildly better than
the last but clearly my standards are
dropping because it is still nowhere
near enough food so she has a waffle
with a few pieces of fruit and syrup her
lunch is apparently just fruit I think
that's like a Luna Bar in there or
something and then for dinner there's
some tofu with some veggies and maybe a
little bit of rice or some other kind of
grain in there doesn't post the calories
but I would estimate that's maybe 800 to
900 calories or so definitely no more
than a thousand we literally also have
one source of protein in there for the
day and maybe a little bit more with the
granola bar but very little fat I mean
your average teen would need twice the
calories easily and while there are
obviously tremendous dangers to anyone
at any age restricting calories like
this the teen years are particularly
sensitive time for undernutrition
nutritional deficiencies particularly
things like iron and calcium as well as
even marginal reductions in energy
intake are associated with severe growth
retardation disordered eating even in
the absence of significant weight loss
has also been associated with menstrual
irregularity and amenorrhea and there is
also a concern that this could
potentially result in osteoporosis in
the long term psychologically research
suggests that dieting and adolescence is
associated with things like fatigue
irritability binging and low self-esteem
teens who diet have an 18 fold increased
risk of developing a full-blown eating
disorder which we know is the most
deadly psychological disorder period
they're also at higher risk of gaining
weight over time with one large study
following over 15,000 preteens for over
three years
suggesting that dieters
significantly more weight than non
dieters I am actually feeling really sad
for this team because diet culture set
her up for this and I feel like some of
these behaviors may have actual lifelong
ramifications so I am making this video
right now as a plea to all of the people
who are young who are watching me to not
go down this same path
you do not want to set yourself up for
reproductive irregularities growth
retardation metabolic disruptions and a
lifetime of struggles in your
relationship with food again I say this
not to scare and definitely not to shame
but as a clearly needed PSA for everyone
to stop this kind of behavior before we
do harm now what is more upsetting to me
is the comments section here while we
definitely have some people who are
trying to make a point that this is
obviously not enough food because it's
not I am seeing a shocking number of
people defending this team saying that
it's totally enough food or that they
eat like this and they feel fine I also
saw comments from other users that the
recommendations were very useful and to
keep up the beautiful work I am really
really hoping that this teen sees this
video that I'm making right now and is
able to see that no short-term weight
loss is worth the long-term damage that
this could do to a growing body now
finally I want to finish off with what
I'll call exhibit 5 by at lunch box food
let's take a look
I mean I can't even really comment on
the adequacy of this diet because it's
such a dangerous representation of a day
of eating for weight loss I mean a
Clementine a few crackers some Tomatoes
a small can of tuna like that's
literally 200 calories and now the
comments on this video repeatedly
question whether or not this is a joke
and when I look at the rest of this
person's channel I would have to assume
that it is you know there's a video of a
snack that includes some chocolate sauce
a pee and lemon juice and then there's
another what I today that starts with a
rotten banana so you know the rest of
this channel is mainly showing like
boxes of Oreos and
ice creams and chips and other
convenience foods it's it's really a
hodgepodge and I'm really not sure what
this individual is trying to communicate
with their content having said that
whether or not this is the individuals
real diet is not really my main point
here I mean even if it were his real
diet then that would be a really sad
point but rather I'm much more concerned
by the impact that this video may have
on people searching for hashtags like
what I in a day and seeing that this is
for weight loss with people who are
struggling with anorexia and other
eating disorders this 200 calories may
look totally normal
it might even look like a lot of food
and the idea of tossing out the granola
bar because they have apparently
eatin too much is a lot of people's
actual day-to-day experiences so if this
is a joke it's a horribly sick one as it
may be incredibly triggering for some
people who struggle with disordered
tendencies or for impressionable viewers
looking for weight-loss inspiration and
thinking that this is what is required
here is the problem with the tik-tok
platform in general when it comes to
delivering nutrition and health
information the videos are just too
short to give any real context this is
partially why I don't use the platform
or snapchat and also why I don't really
do much more than like share links to
blog posts on things like Twitter as
well healthy eating and nutrition is so
nuanced you cannot expect to get the
full story in like 15 seconds and when
you combine the fact there are glaring
omissions in tick-tocks
wellness content with tick-tocks main
demographic we have a recipe for a lot
of dangerous misinformation to be spread
apparently 41% of tik-tok users are
between the ages of 16 and 24 which in
my books is a particularly delicate time
for the onset of disordered eating and
extreme diets research suggests that
more than half of teen girls and 1/3 of
teen boys use unhealthy weight control
behaviors like skipping meals fasting
smoking vomiting and taking laxatives
that's scary a lot of the videos I have
watched here are promoting these
dangerous behaviors that can trigger a
lifetime struggle with food I would also
argue that there's actual pro-ana
content floating around the app
juxtaposed against a number of eating
disorder recovery accounts as well now
while I'm all for helping young people
find a community to help them through
recovery
sometimes even seeing this kind of
content can be triggering for a lot of
people who are actively struggling for
example some recovery videos I saw gifts
civic numbers or weights and give body
checks which can be really triggering
for people who are actively struggling
with their disorders again there just
isn't enough time for nuance and context
in these videos they're really just
given you the polished highlight reel of
what recovery can look like I also do
worry that the apps algorithm might be
really dangerous for this population as
just after I watched a few of these
weight loss what I in a day videos I was
fed a ton of more problematic weight
loss and assorted lis content now I went
through tic TOCs Community Guidelines
and there were actually a few terms that
definitely could deem these videos as
being against the Community Guidelines
so for one they actually say that they
do not permit misinformation that may
cause harm to an individual's health and
two they also do say that they do not
permit any normalizing or encouraging of
triggering self-harm behavior including
content that supports pro-ana or other
dangerous behaviors to lose weight I
know that diet culture has us thinking
that eating less than a thousand
calories is normal or even a healthy
behavior for weight loss but I would
flag all five of these videos as
violating tick-tocks Terms of Use tick
tock
I mean reach out to me or really any
other health professional if you need
some help identifying what is
problematic and what is not because
there is a lot of content on the
platform that needs to come down I just
want to finish here by reminding you to
please be kind to tick tock users who
are posting or promoting this type of
content I actually don't think these
people especially the younger users
really know what is healthy behavior and
what is not ultimately we have all been
socialized to believe that less is more
and our largely relying on misinformed
Wellness influencers for our education
on
trician so I actually have a tremendous
amount of empathy for these tick
stalkers I think everyone's just using
the coping mechanisms that we've been
taught having said that even if you're
not claiming to be a wellness influencer
or recommending a certain way of eating
if you're putting content out into the
world you have to take responsibility
for it and expect that people are going
to follow suit I need everyone watching
right now who has a social media profile
to think really hard about everything
you put out there onto the internet that
people can view and see you don't have
to be saying do this do that to cause
harm anecdotal success stories are very
persuasive
so just seeing one person on the
internet say I ate this and lost this
much weight can be enough to encourage a
lot of other people to follow suit let's
all try to be a little bit more mindful
of that and on that note I think that is
all for me I will definitely be deleting
the app for now until we see a little
better management of this type of
problematic content so friends if you
like this video please be sure to and
give it the thumbs up leave me a compa
lo with your thoughts on this tik-tok
weight-loss content and if you'd like to
see more of this tik tok kind of related
videos maybe one on diet tips or if you
have some kind of other youtubers tic
TOCs accounts that you'd like to see me
review also don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and press the little bells
that you always get a notification when
I release a video and I will see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]